So, let's talk about this.
What kinds of difficulties do women in Japan have when it comes to work?
I can clearly see that nowadays,...
...and women working are getting more and more normal.
It's actually higher than, even in the U.S.
But some people claim that...
...it's not necessarily what Japanese women wanted.
Here in Japan, women are expected to work like men.
It's happening.
It's not like we don't have the power to work.
We could try if we really want to, but we just don't want to.
That's the culture that we have...
...that females like this traditional way of living because we are happy that way.
Actually, not just Yoko,...
...but I've met some other women telling me this.
For those women who don't want to work so much like Japanese men,...
...it's not necessarily a benefit.
Having said that, what if you want to work and pursue your career a lot?
Is Japan really great for you?
For example, if you're job hunting,...
...I feel like women are supposed to work in the back office,...
...not the front office.
A lot of these companies are trying to include women more now.
I guess they're becoming more accepting,...
...but they're much slower than other countries.
Although more and more women work nowadays, like I said earlier,...
...it seems like it's still difficult to develop their career...
...and move up to the ladder.